let's talk about the guy I should have
fired oh yeah from timcast.com Fox News
standing by Jesse Waters after Dr
Anthony fauci called for his firing Fox
News has defended the five host Jesse
Waters after Dr Anthony fauci wants him
fired the controversy began after Waters
told the crowd at last weekend's Turning
Point USA to Ambush fauci with questions
project Veritas style of this human
public and he mentioned going for the
kill shot
and then I gotta say I don't even know
if we can read what he said I get it's
euphemism what Jesse water said but
seriously considering the way they're
reacting it's it's it's pretty overt you
know um the the the metaphors he was
using so referring to an ambush
referring to a Kill Shot saying things
like boom he is dead stuff like that but
we understand that he was he was being
bombastic Jesse Waters was trying to get
a rise in my opinion by saying Ambush
him get these questions ask him this
that or otherwise and boom or whatever
fauci went awful it went off Dr Anthony
fauci says Fox News says Jesse water
should be fired on the spot for Tonga
crowd to Ambush him but he adds he's
gonna go very likely unaccountable I
mean whatever Network he is on is not
going to do anything for him and my
response to this is shut up Fouch you
scumbag you know these people on CNN on
new day are like why Won't Anyone hold
them accountable and I'm like look in a
mirror for two seconds you morons I'm so
sick of these people they March around
around screaming and smashing and and
there's riots and they celebrate and
Collins bails these people out she
donates to them and then the staffer
bite and bail out these riots and then
the moment you get one one Jesse Waters
being like ambushing with some questions
they're like
oh okay you know I don't care I have
look The Divide in this country is too
much there's there's no way to rectify
this if the right keeps capitulating
like every single time a member of
Congress says something off color
they're like fire you know remove them
from their committees and they do yep
and Lauren bobert apologizes to let Omar
for her joke meanwhile and Elmer can
tweet over and over again you know
really weird statements that make it
seem like she's talking about Jewish
people and they're like no we don't care
they're going to keep doing it no one's
gonna hold them accountable and they
live in this Bubble World where all the
Republicans must fall in line with them
and the funny thing is most many other
publicans just do they do because they
care more about the opinion of the New
York Times than they do about their own
constituents well maybe that will change
when y'all go out in the primaries this
spring and summer and vote all the
incumbents out and send them back home
and say you're fired
in that particular voice especially just
like that yeah I do have to say it is
very bold to see Dr fauci calling for
media accountability right you know Mr
Mr gain of function himself he also went
on and also attacked RFK Jr who just
wrote a new book about him uh he said
it's quote strange how they go unchecked
with no consequences for people to say
that and and again he's particularly
referring to RFK Jr and his book The
Real Anthony fauci that details a lot of
very dangerous incredulous studies that
Dr fauci committed throughout his years
at NIH that targeted orphans children
that targeted monkeys that charted uh
you know puppies and and the history of
Dr fauci especially from the AIDS
epidemic is something that's worth
noting worth understanding and to attack
RFK Jr for for making a book on it
because he tries to make people
understand who people are dealing with
is is absolutely crazy
um what what ranking do you think the
real Anthony fauci is on Amazon number
one it's number one yeah number one
number one best seller in books across
just number one the real Anthony fauci
the last time I tried to get a copy it
said they weren't temporarily
unavailable the book yeah really yeah I
don't know if that's still the case but
what do we got here it says temporarily
out of stock wait wait wait wait hold up
aren't these made to order like
you order it and they print it I mean it
was kind of a red flag for me I was just
like interesting so I'd really like to
read this book I mean I understand the
validity of it I understand what it's
because like I listened to an interview
with RFK Jr and he talked about the 250
000 some citations that he has in this
book and he also challenged somebody
like fauci or anybody that he implicates
for the crimes that he alleges in this
book to debate him on stage
I mean he seems to understand what he's
talking about I haven't read the book
I've just heard an interview about it
3327 reviews all five stars yeah well he
gets it 93 are five star wow let's let's
take a look at one of the one star
reviews oh my God they say uh this is
delusional pathetic
um if your family and friends don't hate
you after you fi and find you tolerable
read this book you will lose friends and
be laughed at by sane people your IQ is
not going to lower itself that's crazy
but RFK Jr is not a crackpot he's a
trial lawyer interesting like well
that's why it's so heavily they've been
saying it what else is you guys got the
truth about covet and another best
seller plagues of corruption he's like
it's kind of crazy that this book took
off like this you know because it means
it's got real natural pull people want
to read this they want to know the truth
and they trust this guy not I'm not
saying I I don't know a whole lot about
them to be honest but uh if he's writing
books look
he's gonna be he's gonna have influence
people are going to read it in fact
she's not gonna be happy about it we'll
put it that way yep the last interview
that I heard he was begging for somebody
to find a factual error he said look we
are going to do a second edition if
anybody can point out one factual error
in this book we will do a second edition
we will revise it we will point out the
error that we made and we will put it
out there to the public to review again
and if you lie about someone they could
be sued Dr fauci could sue RFK Jr
especially with the attacks that he's
blaming RFK Jr for but he hasn't he's
just attacking him in the media saying
yeah he's he's causing me to have death
threats no he's criticizing you he's
he's going through your history and
giving people a fair perspective outside
of the corporate media that's worshiping
him uh fauci was on MSNBC just a couple
hours ago and then and the anchor if you
could even call him that I'd you know
this professional Bootlegger was like
thank you for your service you're the
hardest working human being in America
thank you thank you are you ever going
to stop and Dr patches like I'm never
gonna stop I love doing this and I'm
like you got to be freaking kidding me
it was more like an adult film than it
was an interview it sounds like it was a
prayer yeah a prayer to Saint faucially
it was absolutely disgusting to see this
kind of level of of groveling towards
Authority instead of holding it
accountable Dr fauci is a political
figure he has made coveted political
from the very beginning he has not done
interviews with anyone questioning him
not done interviews with anyone saying
hey this is an opposing Viewpoint let's
address it let's let's deal with half of
America that doesn't believe me by going
to their networks by talking to them and
rationally explaining what's going on
here and many other people in the public
field did a way better job addressing a
lot of important issues compared to him
that's hyper partisan super political
and from the very beginning was using
this for political power which he has
been uh telling you lockdown protests
are bad BLM protests are good that's
insane that's crazy but fauci really
embodies government really well like
failure after failure after failure and
he just fails up I think yeah highest
paid bureaucrat that's that's exactly
more specifically he embodies what a
useless bureaucrat does he can totally
misinterpret a criticism and make it
sound like he is the victim and clutches
pearls and then say some nonsense words
and then the criticism just evacuate I
just love how he responded to Rand Paul
you know Rand Paul's like he did gain a
function research and the analogy I like
is you know you go Dr fauci did you
install the door in this room we did not
put a door in the room it is simply a
thin piece of wood with a knob that when
you turn it holds a latch which allows
the paddle to be opened making it easier
for you to access the room and it
unhinges and you're like you just
described a door it is not a door the
best sports have said the best part
about it is Rand Paul's sip of water
lies to his face that simple water is
like it's like eyes are giant he's just
like you don't remind me of it's like it
reminds me of you walk in the kitchen
it's like you know midnight and you've
got like a small kid there and he's on
he's on a chair and he's got the ice
cream in his hand and there's chocolate
over his face and you're like you know
Rand Paul was like uh doc doctor you
know uh son you've got ice cream all
over your face did you take the ice
cream and he's like no it's like what
I'm literally looking at it on your face
it's not ice cream I it's uh
soup it's just chocolate Dairy sugar
that's ice cream kid he literally tried
to cancel Christmas and then he
backtracked when people were like hey
this is absurd like why are you even
making these kind of crazy comments
trying to control people's lives exactly
they were like we're mad at you now he
was like okay you can have Christmas
back that's insane you ever see that
Meme where it's a bunch of uh uh people
wearing masks with like face Shields and
it says normal people and then below
it's a bunch of smiling people eating
Christmas dinner and his conspiracy
theorists
that's the crazy thing to me man yeah
because I got like I know so many people
where they're just like
who was it it was um what's his face
from Queen Brian May is that him you got
he got Mercury no Brian May he got he
got uh kovid but he's triple vaxxed and
his immediate response was make sure you
get your vaccine and I'm like dude stop
stop stop
um because I'm not here to talk science
I'm just here to say that you're the
last person who should be advocating for
that tell people to go talk to a doctor
because if you are like Elizabeth Warren
or Cory Booker or Brian May or Jim
Cramer and you are like I've been triple
facts and I've got kovid too you should
get the vaccine I'm like dude you are
anti-promoting the vaccine by doing that
well you're discouraging it and what
kind of message are you sending yeah and
you know what they say they just say I'm
sure it would have been worse if I
hadn't had this shot well you're running
a parallel universe in that instance you
have no idea what it would be like if
you hadn't had this shot you'd probably
still have gotten well we don't we don't
know we don't know yeah you got Joe
Biden coming out and he's like you know
it was it was the covid protocol guy who
said there's going to be a winter of
death you know for the unvaccinated and
a lot of people were tweeting like this
is not how you convince people and I'm
like it's true it's not how you convince
people but let's be real I don't think
there's any convincing left to be done I
do not believe at this point there's
anything anyone's gonna say to convince
someone to go and get the vaccine or you
know like I I just I think it's a way
it's a pointless argument people have
made up their minds yeah and so they're
resorting to threats yeah yeah I mean
there's no more convincing to be done so
that's what happens you can't convince
somebody okay well maybe you threaten
them extortion and manipulation as
literally talked about by the mayor of
New York City who says we're gonna have
to take away people's ability to get a
paycheck to eat and that's how we're
going to get them to do this and or find
them like they're doing in Austria and
and literally steal money from them and
bring Jack boot thugs in there with
Badges and shine and fancy uniforms to
threaten their lives to do so and I
think that's not a way I want to live in
and that's against human rights and
that's that violates every core
principle of our current civilization
and it's leading to a very dangerous one
where top down bureaucrats have too much
control over your life and I don't want
to live in that kind of existence thanks
for checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
Monday through Friday at 8 pm now don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this Channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time